>> From the Library of Congress,
in Washington, DC.
>> Dan Rothstein is co-Director of the
Right Question Institute and co-Author
with Luz Santana of Make Just One Change,
teach students to ask their own questions.
A former community organizer, urban
planner, and Fulbright Scholar,
he has a BA from Harvard College and a doctorate
from the Harvard Graduate School of Education.
Dan is currently working with
the creators of the C-3 framework
to integrate the question formulation
technique into the inquiry arc.
And I am going to mute myself
and say, welcome Dan,
we are glad to have you with us this evening.
>> Well, welcome everybody.
It's great to be with you.
I'm excited and honored to be able to
participate in this inaugural online conference.
I'm going to give you a quick look at the
question formulation technique and how teachers
around the country at different
levels have used it,
have used it so their students can engage
more effectively with primary sources.
So I'm going to launch right into the process
and we'll have some opportunities for you
to participate and lots of
opportunities to talk at the end.
So, I just wanted to let you know that we
do have a lot of materials available online
on our educator network at RightQuestion.org.
And of course, this one will be
recorded, as you've seen before,
and it will be on the Library
of Congress website.
Okay, we're going to look
at question formulation
as a foundational and transformative skill.
We're going to look first at the development
of the question formulation
technique, how it developed.
We began in 1990.
My co-author, Lose Santana, and I
and several other people were working
on a dropout prevention program
in Lawrence, Massachusetts.
And we heard from parents.
It was a low-income community.
Parents weren't participating
in the children's education.
We heard from them that they
weren't participating
because they didn't even know what to ask.
So we thought, okay, we can solve that problem.
And of course, we did the wrong thing.
We gave them a list of questions and realized
that that only created more dependency on us
to keep on coming up with the questions.
So we went to work at figuring out how you
teach what is really a very sophisticated skill,
that very often is learned only through years
of professional training
and practice, to all people.
And it was a long process of trial and error.
Eventually, we came upon a process,
the question formulation technique,
that's been used in multiple fields.
There's been research done on it and
its application to family engagement.
There's been a lot of work and
researched done its use in healthcare
with the National Institutes of
Health Study showing the doubling
and tripling of patient participation.
And there's been a lot of interest
in the private sector recently,
thanks to Warner Burgers book, "A More Beautiful
Question," where he featured our work as,
if you want people to learn
how to ask questions,
here's an effective strategy for doing it.
So it's been used in many places.
And of course, it's been used in the classroom.
When we published our book a few years
ago, we didn't know quite what to expect.
But what we've seen is an educator-led
movement, teachers and educators at all levels,
who have embraced the question
formulation technique.
More than 100,000 educators
around the world are using it.
And using it not that it's
required or mandated in any setting,
but because it addresses a
problem that they recognize.
And that's, you know, part of the reason why
that they're using it is
perhaps captured in these charts.
You can see in this chart, a basic skill
attainment, that shows a generally upward slope
of reading skills and writing skills.
And then if you look at this chart,
you see the yellow line going down,
and that's the slope of asking questions.
And you see a sharp drop off from
4-year-olds going reaching the peak,
and then a sharp drop-off after that.
Now, part of the reason for that is because, as
you all know, there's a lot of pressure to focus
on answers, answers to tests and
exams, getting the right answers.
And certainly getting the right answers is a
good goal, but there's also a role for the skill
of question formulation and developing that
skill in order to get to better answers.
And I think that that's being
recognized today because, for example,
there's a strong movement towards inquiry-based
learning, the Common Core state standards,
Next-Generation of Science
standards, college, and of course,
the C-3 framework for social studies
where they've done a great job
at building inquiry right through the process.
And we're excited now to be working with them
and how to use the question formulation
technique as part of that process.
So we are looking at how
to accelerate the movement
from teacher questions to student questions.
When students ask questions, their questions
become a catalyst for greater curiosity,
for engagement, for ownership,
and for deeper learning.
And so I'm going to give
you a quick introduction now
to how the question formulation
technique does that.
It basically helps accelerate the shift, in
that one shift, from teachers asking questions
of students to students asking
their own questions.
It distills some of the best pedagogical
practices into a very simple teaching
and learning process that makes it assessable
for all teachers, novices and veterans alike.
And it offers a shortcut to student
engagement, ownership, and deeper learning.
So any -- when the question formulation
technique is used in the classroom,
students learn to work with their
questions, and that specifically means
that they're producing their own
questions, which is significant on its own.
They're actually working with their
questions to improve their questions.
They strategize on how to use their questions.
And as part of the process, they reflect on
what they have learned and how they learned it.
So now, let's take a look at the question
formulation technique in practice,
and give you an opportunity
to ask some questions.
So let's look at this set of rules that
we've created for producing questions.
There are 4 rules here.
I want you to know that it took us
about 8 years to create those 4 rules.
Now, I'm sure you're all doing the math there
and figuring that we've done 1/2 a rule a year.
Actually, what we had to do is we had to figure
out how not to create a list of a hundred rules
on how to get students who were
not accustomed to asking questions
to actually start producing questions.
And we tried to look at what's
the simplest way to do that.
And here are the 4 rules.
Number 1, ask as many questions as you can.
Two, do not stop to answer, judge, or discuss.
Three, write down every question
exactly as stated.
And 4, change any statements into questions.
Of course, we would like the first
one, ask as many questions as you can,
to be sufficient, but as you know, it's not.
There's a need to create a structure
and a safe space for doing that.
So take a moment, look at those questions,
and think about what might be difficult
for you in following these rules.
Which of the rules do you think might
be most difficult for you to follow?
So we're going to now take a look at
an example, and you're going to get
to use these rules and ask some questions.
So I'm going to show you now
what we call a question focus,
which is meant to be the
catalyst for student questions.
So it's not a question from
the teacher of the students,
but rather it's a teacher designed selected
focus for them to start asking questions.
So here, take a look at this question focus.
Take a moment there.
That's the caning of sumner, and
it may be familiar to you all.
And it happened in the US Senate in 1856.
So you're now going to get a chance to look at
some student questions, but before you do that,
what are some questions that you
might ask about this question focus?
Remember not to edit yourselves.
Write down a few questions
as quickly as you can.
Okay, I would love for you to be able to keep
on asking questions, but I'm going to take you
through the whole process to take a look at it.
And I seen in a lot of the questions in the chat
that you'll enjoy seeing the sixth-graders'
questions as I present them to you now.
So this was a teacher here in
the Boston, Massachusetts, area,
teaching a unit on the Civil War.
And she used the question focus and
the question formulation technique
as a pre-reading activity
to engage the students.
So now let's look at their questions.
Why are they fighting?
Are they fighting?
Are they part of the government?
Where were they?
Very key question that they
asking right up front there.
What started the fight?
Who are they?
Were they signing anything?
Who else was there?
Why are you hitting him?
Which, of course, is a great
middle school question too.
And then, why didn't they call 911?
So that's one to enjoy there
in the middle of this list.
But look at the very next question.
Was this related to slavery?
And it moves all the way through to the end.
Why are they smiling?
And I notice from the chat that somebody
asked a question about that as well.
Somebody else asked a question about the end.
So you'll see that you had questions that were
similar to the questions that they were asking.
I love number 15 as well.
Who hit who first?
Which is truly a great middle school question.
So there you see what happens
when students get a chance
to produce their own questions
following those rules.
If you look at question number
18, why are they smiling,
that's a detail that I certainly had missed.
I know that some of you had not missed it.
And it's a really interesting thing for them to
be observing, that shows the level of engagement
with the primary source of how
carefully they are looking at it.
So now, let's look at the next step
in the question formulation technique.
And that's where we have students think about
open-ended questions and closed-ended questions.
We use a simple definition of
close-ended as being able to answer
with a yes or no or a one-word answer.
And open-ended questions
requiring more explanation.
And in the process, we would have
students identify the questions
as close-ended or open-ended.
And it's always very interesting to see them do
this work, find that there are some questions
that are kind of in the gray area,
they're not quite sure what to do.
But they're becoming more sophisticated as
they're actually working with their questions.
And at that point, we asked them to think about,
what are some of the advantages
of close-ended questions.
And that sometimes is a bit of a shock
because they might've gotten the message
that open-ended questions are better than
close-ended questions, so they first start
to have to think about, what are some
advantages of a close-ended question.
So as you think about that, what are
some things that come to mind for you
about some advantages to a close-ended question?
Then we have them move on
to look at disadvantages.
What are some disadvantages
of close-ended question?
So in the advantages, they very often will
talk about, it's quick, you get a quick answer,
you can focus on the next question
that you need to be asking.
The disadvantages sometimes, it
limits the information you're getting,
it cuts off discussion.
So then we have them move on to
look at open-ended questions.
And ask them to think about the
advantages of open-ended questions.
And they come up with comments that are --
would be familiar to you in
terms of invites discussion,
allows for further explanation,
more exploration.
And then when they think about disadvantages,
they also identify some of the challenges.
Sometimes you can get an answer that overwhelms
you, that you don't quite know what to do
with it, you're not clear
about what the answer is.
So they realize that there's
advantages and disadvantages
to both closed and open-ended questions.
The important thing is to be able
to ask different kinds of questions
and to have the ability to take an open-ended
question and change it to a closed to see
if that helps you with your work, or vice versa,
to take a closed and change it to an open.
So let's look at how one class did this.
So in taking the close-ended and changing it
to open and taking an open-ended to a close,
I bring you this example from
Lexington, Massachusetts,
Maureen Bennett, a third-grade teacher.
And she was introducing unit
on the Mayflower Compact.
And the question focus was very
simply, the Mayflower Compact.
The students viewed the primary source on iPads.
So take a look at it, that's
the Mayflower Compact.
The students were looking at it, and their job
was to follow those rules that we introduced
to you earlier and ask questions.
So now, when I'm going to show
you here, and this part is not --
we're not going to look at all their questions,
we're just going to zero in on the ones
that they changed from open to closed and closed
to open, so you can see how that process works.
So their student questions, look at number 5.
Did the Indians sign it?
And understood that that
was a close-ended question,
and they want to move it
to an open-ended question.
So they asked how many Indians signed it,
which is very interesting thinking
about trying to open that up.
And again, they could see
advantages and disadvantages,
where they could see the advantages of getting
a definitive answer to their first question.
But it was good for them to practice changing
the question, thinking about it some more.
And the question right after that
is, did the Pilgrims sign it?
And then opening it up to, who signed it?
Where they wanted to explore
who might have signed it,
maybe who didn't sign it, who
was included in the signing.
So it allowed them an opportunity
to expand their horizons.
And then their last question
there, who is Lord James.
And that got them thinking about text
that they're reading in the compact,
and they wanted to know was Lord
James asking what is furtherance.
So they were grappling with a very
difficult text, asking questions about it,
practicing changing their questions from closed
to open and open to closed and discovering
that they had more questions to ask.
So now, let's take a look at
the next step in the process
of the question formulation technique.
Prioritizing questions.
So students have produced their questions,
they've done some work on open and closed,
they've changed them, they've identified them.
And now we want students to be prioritizing.
Prioritization instructions should be connected
to your teaching and learning objectives
and to your plan for using
the student questions.
So here are some examples of prioritization
instructions that you could give.
Choose 3 questions that you
consider most important.
That instruction gets them thinking
about what's important to them.
And that's a wide-open invitation.
It is a very open-ended invitation for them to
do thinking and for them to prioritize based
on what interests them or
they consider most important.
Then there's a different kind of
prioritization instructions where you're going
to have them do research and you want them
to start thinking about research questions.
So you want them to choose 3 that
will help them with their research.
Then maybe in a different setting, you might
want to use the question formulation technique
for a specific reading assignment purpose.
So you might give them the prioritization
instruction of choose 3 questions
that can be answered as you read.
And as you look at the last one, you can give
an instruction that, if you think about it,
it's similar to what the Stanford
History Education Group's reading,
like a historian emphasizes about
the importance of students thinking
about the author's point of view.
So you could give instructions that say
choose 3 questions that will help you
to explore the author's point of view.
So it's a robust model that allows you with
your teaching goals and specific content
that you're teaching, specific objectives, for
you to be able to get the students thinking
on their own about the key issues.
So let's look at an example
of that prioritization.
This is a eighth-grade classroom in a rural
New Hampshire town, taught by Joshua Bier.
And he had just done a unit
on American imperialism.
And so he's using the question formulation
technique for summative assessment purposes.
And if you think about that, you had
just looked at 2 examples of teachers
who were using it at the beginning of the unit.
Here, Josh Bier is using
it at the end of the unit.
And here was his queue focus, that's
what we call the question focus.
It's very simple.
Questions that should be asked about American
imperialism at the turn of the 20th century.
So they've just studied American
imperialism at the turn of the 20 century,
and he wants them to come up with a list of
questions that can be used on the final exam.
So their job is to come up with
questions that should be asked
about American imperialism at
the turn of the 20th century.
So let's take a look at what they did.
They came up with a lot of questions.
I'm just showing you here just
one group's set of questions.
They were working in small
groups, there were different groups
with different sets of questions.
And this group chose as their
3 priority questions.
Why did the Hawaiian natives in Quin not
want the United States to annex Hawaii?
So there you see the level of specificity and
specific situation they wanted to know about,
and they felt that that is a
question that should be answered
about American imperialism at
the turn of the 20th century.
Then you leap to question number 10.
How does the Spanish-American
war effect America?
So there's a global question, a
large question, with an understanding
of policy implications and changes in society.
And then you look at number 12, which
actually didn't exist on the original list.
It was originally question number 6.
Which was, what was Alfred Their
Mann's stance on imperialism?
And they changed it to, why did Alfred Their
Mann have the stance that he did on imperialism?
So there you've got them working
on the author's perspective
on a significant influence on imperialism.
And look at the very next
question that they asked.
Did Alfred Their Mann's book
influence imperialism?
So there you see they prioritized.
And it's really interesting when you look at
this example, that you can actually see this
on our website, there is the full video
of them using this in a classroom.
I'm going to show you now a very
quick trailer from that video
so you can see them doing this work
with the question formulation technique.
>> What country developed the most?
>> Why did the United States
want to annex Hawaii?
>> [inaudible] Panama Canal?
>> The purpose is to get them thinking,
to get them questioning what
do I know about this subject.
And the great thing about working in groups
is that if you come up with a question,
that may generate a whole new line of thinking
for me, then I can add an additional question
that may generate another line
of thinking from somebody else.
>> Who was the biggest anti-imperialist?
>> [inaudible] All of these could go either way.
>> Why is it so important for
America to have overseas bases open?
>> It covers a wide variety of what
happened in the imperialistic era.
>> You could ask one main question and
then build questions off of that question
and it makes me think more and you
have to pull stuff out of your brain.
And when you do that, you
have to remember it again.
And the more you take it out and remember
it again, the deeper it gets into your brain
and the more easier it is to remember.
>> You never really know what you know
about the subject until you see it
from others and your own point of view.
>> I think that's one of the great things about
using the question formulation technique is,
it's automatic engagement for the
students, because they're interested in it,
they get to view their voice, their
opinions, their thoughts, and their questions.
>> So I hope you enjoyed that trailer, and
you can see the whole video on our website.
So let's take a look at the next
step of students sharing their work.
They can share the questions that they change.
They learn from each other about
how they change the questions.
They share their priority questions.
And also they share the numbers of where
in their sequence original questions
did their priority questions fall.
So it's very interesting when they see
that, and I'll talk about that in a moment.
And then they share their rationale for
why they chose those priority questions.
And they can discuss and share their next
steps for working with their questions.
So then they go through all that process.
And at the very end, there is
a piece, a part for reflection,
where the students are asked,
what did you learn?
How did you learn it?
And what do you understand
differently now for you
about students learning to
ask their own questions?
So that's a question that I have for you.
What do you understand differently now about
students learning to ask their own questions?
Take a moment and think about that, and then
I want to share with you some specific aspects
of the why and how the QFT the
question formulation technique works.
Okay, let's take a look at some
specific aspects of the process.
We'll unpack the process and the outcomes.
In the question formulation technique, there are
actually 3 thinking abilities that are embedded
into one process, and this is part of the rigor
that is in the question formulation technique.
They're doing rigorous thinking, rigorous
work as they go through the different steps.
And they're not all blended together, they are
purposely separated so that they're able to work
on each of these thinking
abilities at a specific time.
So let's look at the first one.
The students begin to think
in many different directions.
They do divergent thinking.
So the 4 rules that we came up with, that we
told you took us 8 years to come up with them ,
are really trying to create that space
and the structure and the rigor for them
to do more than, I've got
one question and no more.
And I'm sure many of you have seen this,
many teachers have talked about trying
to invite questions and get questions
from students can feel like pulling teeth.
Or they'll get questions
from 1 or 2 or 3 students,
but they'll not hear from other students.
So the idea of using those
rules is to create the structure
for students to do divergent thinking.
It's hard to do divergent thinking if you don't
have a process and a structure for doing that.
Then they move to a different kind of
thinking, narrowing down and focusing,
they begin to do convergent thinking.
And they do convergent thinking as they begin to
look at their open and closed-ended questions.
They begin to practice changing them.
They are looking more carefully,
more closely at their questions.
And then they prioritize their questions.
And when they're prioritizing their
questions, they are continuing with the kind
of sophisticated convergent thinking that
should come after divergent thinking.
So there's a sequence here.
Now there's one more thinking ability, that's a
very sophisticated thinking ability that's built
into the question formulation technique.
And it's thinking about thinking,
metacognitive thinking.
And there are several steps in that process
that students are thinking about their thinking.
Beginning with when they're
asked, what might be different
about following the 4 rules
for producing questions.
They have to think about how do they usually
operate, and what's different about it,
what are the rules require of them in
their thinking and working process.
They have to think about
advantages and disadvantages
of open and closed-ended questions.
They have to think about why they
chose their priority questions,
what's their rationale for that.
And then, even when they see
the sequence of questions,
very often they notice they might have a
priority question from the first grouping,
something from the middle,
something from the end.
And they realize that one of their priority
questions didn't come until the end.
And so they got to see the value of working with
their questions to advance their own thinking.
So what happens, what do the teachers see
when students go through this process?
They see students who are
more curious and engaged.
We take greater ownership and are more
confident working with primary sources.
Which, instead of it being intimidating,
unfamiliar, and difficult, it becomes something
that they are looking at very, very
carefully, and they have their own set
of questions now to look at that.
And what do students say?
Students say many different things about
how they are learning this process.
Here's a sixth grader in Palo
Alto, California, who said,
just when you think you know all you
need to know, you ask another question
and discover how much more there is to learn.
And then think about this statement from
a high school student in Boston, who said,
when you ask the question, you feel
like it's your job to get the answer.
Just think about that, think
about the feeling for you,
think about the feeling for that student.
It's not their job to give you the answer to
your question, they've set a learning agenda,
they feel like it's their job to get the answer.
And look at this one last student reflection.
This is a ninth grade student who was
in a remedial summer school
program at risk of being held back.
And when asked what he had learned
by learning to ask his own questions
in the summer school program, said,
the way it made me feel was smart,
because I was asking good
questions and giving good answers.
So if you think back to those charts
at the beginning of this presentation,
and you think about what we talked about
in terms of the pressure to get to answers,
the students discover that by
learning to ask good questions,
by learning to ask their own questions,
by working with their own questions,
they can get to good answers.
And that adjective that he used to describe
himself, smart, is a very significant one
for a student who was in the summer
school program that he was in.
So those are the kinds of
changes that you see in students.
Here's a reflection from a teacher.
This is the third grade teacher, Maureen
Bennet, in Lexington, Massachusetts, who said,
the question formulation technique
was a great segueway into the unit.
I noticed that the students were fully
engaged and excited to try to figure
out what this document was all about.
Having them generate their own
questions about this made the lesson
so much more powerful than ever before.
So let's take a final look at the
question formulation technique
and its universal relevance across disciplines,
grade levels, subject areas, and communities.
So the research confirms the
importance of student questioning.
John Haddi talks about self-questioning
as the metacognitive strategy,
that students formulating
their own questions prove
to be one the most effective
metacognitive strategies.
Engaging in pre-lesson self-questioning improves
student's rate of learning by nearly 50%.
And here's this wonderful quote from
the historian David Hackett Fischer.
We talked about how questions are the
engines of intellect, the cerebral machines
which convert energy to motion,
and curiosity to control inquiry.
He wrote this way back in 1971.
And I love how it captures what students
are now doing all around the country
and all around the world as they're
converting that energy into motion,
into action, into a research agenda.
They're converting that curiosity to a very
disciplined rigorous controlled inquiry.
So I love how that quote
in a sense anticipates much
of what we're now seeing all students
being able to do on their own.
Now, let's take a moment
and look at the importance
of students working with their own questions.
So there's a little note
there about at the bottom,
this was a subliminal message
that I'm making explicit now.
This was a photo shot that I used
at the beginning of the process
of the question formulation
technique, and you see a student there
with marker in hand, writing and working.
Another student looking at the list
and pointing, making discussions.
You can see where they've marked
some questions with an O for open.
So you see that kind of work, it's
students working with their own questions.
And when they do that, it
becomes a transformative skill.
We believe it's a foundational skill
that should be taught to all students,
and it is also a transformative skill.
Allow students to go from confusion
to a clear learning agenda.
It allows them to move towards better answers.
It increases engagement and ownership, and
allows for genuine inquiry in the classroom.
And not to be forgotten is what teachers report,
is that it provides a little more
joy in a very demanding profession.
When you see your students really excited about
their own questions and their learning agenda.
And then is one more reason for
us to think about the importance
of teaching the skill question formulation.
Democracy.
The woman seated in the center of the
picture there, seated at the table there,
is Septima Clark, one of the great
educators of the 20th century,
great relatively unknown
educators of the 20th century.
Who in 1955, was fired by the Charleston, South
Carolina Board of Education after 18 years
of teaching because she was
a member of the NAACP.
So she and her cousin, Bernice Robinson,
who is standing behind her there,
organized citizenship schools, in
which they organized to teach adults
in the community basic literacy skills
so they could learn to help themselves,
not get cheated out of wages,
and begin to prepare
for a larger agenda of participating
in democracy.
And that's really the opportunity
that we all have when we're sharing
and teaching the skill question
formulation, is we're building civic capacity
through a foundational democratic skill.
It's possible to imagine a
dictatorship without questions,
without citizens being able to ask questions.
But it's not possible to imagine
a democracy without questions.
And so we are delighted to share
the question formulation technique.
Delighted the opportunity we've had to work
with teaching primary sources at the Library
of Congress with our partners at C3
and the social studies framework,
to be working with teachers
and educators in all areas
to help build this fundamental learning
skill, this fundamental thinking skill,
a fundamental life skill, and
a fundamental democratic skill.
So thank you all very much, and
I look forward to our discussion.
Keep in mind Septima Clark's words, we need
to be taught to study rather than to believe,
to inquire rather than to affirm.
And I want to thank Josh Bier and his class,
at the Goshen-Lempster School in New Hampshire.
You can see an educational leadership article
that has more about his work and teachers
in other parts of the country, and you can
access the full video that was previewed here.
And thank you to our team here
at the Right Question Institute
who helped make this session possible.
And as I mentioned earlier, there
are more resources available
on the question formulation
technique at the RightQuestion.org.
So I look forward to your
questions and the discussion.
>> Fantastic, Dan.
This is Cheryl again.
I've been harvesting questions.
And the first one has to do with how teachers
manage the time that this technique might take.
>> Okay, that's a common question and a concern.
The very first time that you use
the question formulation technique,
it is something where you actually are
having the students discuss the rules,
think about them, discuss
advantages and disadvantages.
So if you give them -- you
can do this in 35, 40 minutes.
You can do this in a class in one class
hour, depending on how much time you want
to give them doing work in small groups.
But once they learn this, it becomes something
that becomes part of second nature for them.
They know they're able to do this quickly.
You can get it done in 10 minutes.
You can get it done as a do now at the beginning
of a class, where you present a question focus
and the students at the beginning are
actually generating their own questions.
You can do it as a homework assignment.
Students learn how to do this on their own.
So you are developing the skill, you're
giving them different opportunities
to continue to practice the skill.
And like any skill, it's
something that you get better
at the more you practice, and
you can do it more quickly.
So yes, there is a commitment the very first
time did you do it, but then you modify it
so that you don't have full discussions of
all the different aspects of the process,
and they just get to work on asking their
questions, changing them, prioritizing,
and planning on next steps
what they're going to do.
>> Thank you, that's a really helpful answer.
Along the same lines, somebody
asked how she can meet her goals
when the students are forming the questions.
What are your experiences around that, please?
>> Right, that's also very important to address.
Which is, we weren't able
to fully get into this year.
But when you design the question
focus, you're designing it
with the content that you need to teach in mind.
When you are designing the prioritization
instructions, you're doing it with the teaching
and learning goals that you have in mind,
including the specific things
the students will be doing.
So that's why if you think about the teachers
chose a question focus that was related
to what they needed to teach,
what needed to be covered.
When they chose their prioritization
instructions,
it was based on what do they now want
students after they've done this thinking
about this topic, what do we want to be zeroing
in on to be prioritizing so that when they move
into the next steps, it's going to be
connected to what I'm teaching and learning.
So it's not disconnected from that, it's
actually shaped by what you need to teach.
>> Terrific.
So along the same lines, Dan, I'm
wondering what you've encountered in terms
of teachers regarding this is a
shift in practice, and particularly,
I've been wondering how it differs from
other approaches to student questioning
where teachers might provide question
stems and really shape that more carefully.
This technique seems much more open.
>> Right, well, it's very interesting.
This is a deceptively simple technique,
and it's also deceptively open.
Because there's actually a very
rigorous structure here that you work
with that structure, in a sense,
there's the art and the science
of the question formulation technique.
Not saying that we discuss at length in our book
make just one change, but the shorthand version
of it here is that you are able to
basically take what you need to cover,
and you design it in a way so that they're
able to zero in on the on the key topics
and on what they need to be thinking about.
So I'm not sure if that answered your question.
>> It certainly gives me lots to think
about, and I'm going to turn this
out to the participants and say, if you have
questions around this, go ahead and put them
in the chat box and we'll
catch as many as we can.
So, Dan, how widely has this technique been
implemented if I'm not necessarily looking
for an exact number, but
how widely is it being used?
And did you have any surprises when you
took it into a school or a district?
>> Well, I think that we've been inspired
by just seeing how teachers have been hungry
for this, this is the dream of many teachers
to see their students working with questions,
asking questions, engaged, taking ownership.
So it's been a very exciting process.
I have to share with you
all a little kind of secret.
That when we were asked to write the
book because there were some examples
of teachers using it, we barely
had 5 stories, full stories,
of teachers around the country using the
question formulation technique in the classroom,
and one of whom was my daughter, who was in
her first year of teaching in New York City.
So maybe that invalidated the pool even
further, I'm not sure, although some people say
that might've actually validated the
technique even more, don't know about that.
But we were able to put the stories together
and illustrate how do you use the question
formulation technique, and since then,
it's been an educator-driven movement.
And that's what's really been
one surprising and wonderful.
And we've seen the kind of initiative
that's been taken by people who pick
up on this and find ways to bring this in.
So with teaching of primary sources, you have
Mary Johnson's work, who tweeted about this,
and we connected through twitter.
And the next thing we know, we were doing work
with the Western region of
teaching the primary sources.
And since then, they've brought
it to more people
within your network and around the country.
And that's what we see community
after community.
And what's also really exciting is that it's
being used across all kinds of communities,
urban, suburban, rural, elementary,
middle, high school, and higher ed.
I just came back from a meeting
today at Harvard Medical School,
where I gave a keynote address last year on
the art and science of asking better questions.
And there's a recognition at the medical
school that their students are very good
at answering questions, but they need to
get better at asking their own questions.
So there's just a lot of excitement among
educators that inspires us to keep moving.
>> Sounds like this has huge ramifications, and
I'm seeing a lot of excitement in the chat too.
One of the questions that just came in,
and Andrew nodded toward it in the chat,
but maybe you can expand
on this just a little bit.
And we we're running close on time, so
we'll see if we get any questions past this.
Do you have any research or
examples of kindergartners
or first-graders using this technique?
>> yes. And there are some wonderful
examples of teachers using it.
And actually, on our blog post, which I
think our blog, which Andrew just mentioned
in the chat, there are examples
of a first-grade teacher who wrote
about using the question formulation
technique in his class with examples of that.
There are teachers around the country who
are doing that who are tweeting about it.
So there are a lot of examples of that.
>> I will get that link to the blog out.
We're working on that.
So we want to move into the wrapping up pieces.
Thanks, Andrew, for putting
that link to the blog.
We want to thank everybody for joining us.
We will be in communication via email
within 5 business days with directions
on how to access your certificate.
I want to thank you all so much
for participating, for joining,
for your energy, your enthusiasm,
your questions.
And we are going to end the
recording and the session now.
Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.